packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life
right now it's all about outstanding
brunches
i love brunch it's a great way of
relaxing with friends and family not
taking yourself or anything else too
seriously
and brunch dishes should reflect that
spicy sweet or savoury anything goes
and one of my all-time favorites a dish
that always creates a stir is the daddy
of all brunches
steak sandwiches
[Music]
for me the secret of a great brunch is
fun and casual fuss-free cooking and
everyone helping themselves
this is the ultimate steak sandwich
you want the rolls royce of beef it has
to be fill it now season it beautifully
i like to open up
the top of the peppermill to increase
the size of the pepper in the steak so
it gives that bit of heat
nice little chunks
you just roll now
nicely all the way around
now slice the garlic
in half
pan nice and hot
olive oil in
[Music]
hold the steak and just place it into
the pan don't drop it
at the front of the pan
we're going to tilt the pan forward to
cook the back of the steak dual purpose
now roll it back
and sear underneath
next
my garlic
and roast that garlic
time
fry that time i want to hear it we're
not looking for a lot of color
because you're going to dry out the fill
it so
just
one end
turn it back down
and stir the other end in
lift up your time place it on top of the
garlic
there
lift up your fillet
and sit there on
top
of your garlic
butter in
take a spoon
tilt the pan gently
lift up
and baste
i've got that scented garlic
thyme flavor
the steak is going to cook evenly
because it's sat on a little
a little bed
in the oven for 8 to 10 minutes
[Music]
pan on
for the relish you think of a steak
sandwich you think of a sort of nice
heated tomato relish
to make the relish finely dice a red
onion three finger rule one in front
two behind
through
and chop wow
next roughly chop a chili keeping the
seeds in for extra heat start off with
the olive oil
into a pan
onions
chili
generous with the olive oil
i want a nice sort of rich
silky
relish
from there
take your tomatoes you can't just use
red tomatoes but these yellow
and red make the perfect combination
now put your salt in
pepper
and then
roast those tomatoes off
take a wooden spoon and just sort of
break them up
once the skins blister
the whole tomato just starts to release
all that really nice sweet
texture
a little teaspoon of cherry vinegar
gives that nice acidic balance the
sweetness of the tomatoes turn down the
gas and just let them sort of stew
perfectly
now a steak sandwich would not be
complete unless it had the most amazing
mustard mayonnaise
simply add three tablespoons of
mayonnaise to three teaspoons of whole
grain mustard
[Music]
now i've got the reddish almost down to
like a really nice jam now
i want to make that relish a little bit
more fragrant
some basil
slice it through
sprinkle that basil in there
[Music]
beautiful
look at this
there she is
my crown jewels
time to take it out
smell
is incredible
just based one more time
to fill it
touch is quite soft in the center so
it's just coming up to mid-rare let it
rest at the same time you cooked it
it'll be nice and pink evenly throughout
the steak
to make my sandwich i'm going to char
grill some sliced chipatta bread season
it nicely
just a little drizzle of olive oil i
want to get that bread nice and crispy
pan nice and hot
bread
in
push it down smell is amazing that char
sort of charcoal flavor
once you've got those marks on the bread
it just stops the bread from becoming
soggy and look at this here
it is
stunning
on
slice it
gently
one beautiful slice
wow
it's nice and pink all the way through
and the beef is so soft
it's almost like slicing through butter
let the knife do the work
take
a little bit of mayonnaise spread that
the back of the spoon
on both sides
next
lettuce
take that beautiful slice of beef
and then relish
on top of that beef and just slice the
sandwich in half
beautiful
now that's what i call a steak sandwich
trust me sir the sublime sandwich for
brunch and you'll put a smile on
everyone's face
[Music]
next up my guide to buying the best beef
and steaks
if you want the ultimate brunch you
can't do any better than start with a
perfect steak and one man who really
knows his steak is master butcher danny
lidgate steak is my favorite type of
meat and i think it's really good to
enjoy different varieties of steak when
choosing a steak that you want you need
to look at exactly what you want out of
it for my ultimate steak sandwich i used
to fill it because it's the most tender
the fillet does the least amount of work
than all the other mussels it's tucked
away in the rib cage this means that
when you find a fillet
it's incredibly soft like butter it's
the most expensive but you get what you
pay for
there's a wide array of cuts to choose
from all different in taste and texture
if in doubt ask your butcher
this would be the rump section where the
rump comes from
which is basically the back side take
the bone out and what you're left with
is a wonderful steak rum steak
characteristically a little bit tougher
than the sirloin or a little bit chewier
than the ribeye but a really strong
flavor for the steak again when frying
rum look for the marbling try and get
some fat covering on the steak you can
always cut it off after it's cooked
rumps one of the best value steaks i
love it thinly cut them flesh fried in
stir fries or simply marinated and
whacked on the barbecue another great
value but delicious cut is the hanger
steak known as the butcher's cut because
they often keep it for themselves it's
great marinated and cooked quickly
with the sirloin which is basically the
back of the animal a nice sirloin like
this really well marbled don't buy too
lean
so once the sirloin is trimmed up
it looks something like this
not too much fat
but you need a little bit to cook in it
next to the sirloin
is the rib
really popular now with rib eyes small
nice
really tender juicy steaks it's really
especially good for barbecuing or
grilling fantastic probably my favorite
steak would be a rib eye
rib eye is especially delicious because
the marbling in the meat loads it with
flavor
for a full-on steak experience try the
t-bone steak with a small tender fillet
steak on one side of the bone and a
larger flavor some sirloin on the other
[Music]
take your butcher's advice and you won't
go wrong the final word has to go to
danny
when buying meat knowledge really is
power so it's important to ask as many
questions about the meat you're buying
find out the breeds how it's aged and
decide exactly what you want to do each
particular job that should then give you
a really amazing end product
[Music]
the great thing about brunch is there
are no rules the only thing i insist on
are it's got to be fuss-free easy to
cook and so delicious it puts you in a
good mood for the rest of the day
and for me pancakes always hit the spot
here are three of my deliciously
different recipes certified to liven up
your mornings
first up fluffy blueberry and ricotta
pancakes with yogurt
[Music]
start by adding 125 grams of plain flour
a teaspoon of baking powder
a pinch of salt a tablespoon of sugar
then create a wet in the center
separate two eggs and add the yolks
keeping the whites for later
beat the yolks into the flour pouring in
milk gradually to form a smooth batter
[Music]
next fold in 125 grams of creamy ricotta
cheese and 100 grams of fresh
blueberries
[Music]
now whisk your egg whites until they
almost reach soft peaks
then gently fold into the pancake mix
keep it in the air to make sure the
pancakes are extra light and really
fluffy
add olive oil and butter into a hot pan
then spoon in the mix to make small
pancakes cooking until golden brown on
both sides
to finish top with greek yogurt
fresh blueberries
and drizzle over lovely runny honey
sweet savory fruity and delicious made
in 15 minutes perfect brunch pancakes
my second simple pancake brunch recipe
is
succulent crab and mascarpone crepes
[Music]
for the filling put cooked white crab
meat into a bowl add in mascarpone
the zest and juice of a lemon
finely chopped chives and for a spicy
hit cayenne pepper
stir
and set aside
for the pancake batter simply add flour
salt
an egg
and milk
then whisk into a smooth mixture
add oil to a hot nonstick pan
ladle in batter to cover the bottom and
swirl it around spreading out nice and
thinly
when lovely and golden flip over turn
out and spoon the delicious crab mix
into the center of the pancake and roll
finally sprinkle with some chopped
chives and devour
my second pancake recipe mascarpone
crepes a fantastic easy brunch cooked in
minutes
[Music]
when you want your pancakes sweet and
zingy this recipe is perfect
coconut pancakes with mango and lime
syrup
[Music]
for the lime syrup simply add water
cast the sugar
the zest and juice of the lime and
simmer for 10 minutes
to make the easy pancake batter put
flour
baking powder and desiccated coconut
into a bowl then crack in an egg
add coconut milk
and whisk into the batter until well
combined
sweeten with runny honey
now you're ready to fry add melted
butter to a hot pan
place in heap teaspoons of batter flip
and cook until golden for a lovely
vibrant wake up serve with sliced fresh
mango and drizzle over the gorgeous
citrusy syrup
sweet sticky and utterly irresistible
ready in under 20 minutes the ultimate
indulgent pancakes
fast to prepare easy to make three
effortless recipes guaranteed to bring
some sparkle to your brunches
incredible welcome back to my ultimate
cookery course
i'm teaching you all about brunches the
most laid-back meal of the week and if
you want to take it easy having the
right equipment makes all the difference
[Music]
here's my guide to the best kitchen
equipment
everything you need to know about the
basic kit that will get you cooking
fantastic food
chopping boards
for brunch one of the most useful things
is a great chopping board get the right
one and it'll be your friend for life
i prefer a sort of heavy duty one
because they're so much more durable
they can be flipped over the minute you
want to go from vegetables to prepping
fish or meat always keep a little jake
off underneath that actually stops the
board from sliding
carefully wooden board by rubbing it
with oil every so often any cooking oil
will do
wooden boards for me are always the best
easy to clean and long lasting
when you do wash your wooden board never
let it stand in water or put it in the
dishwasher as it may split buy the best
you can afford and take good care of it
[Music]
for brunch i'd love something sweet and
i've always been a fan of classic
british crumpets with butter and jam
but once you try cooking them at home
you'll never want to buy them from shops
again
this is another great recipe you can
stake your life on
it's my homemade crumpet
whether you're cooking for two three or
even a gang some of the best brunch
dishes are always the simplest
these crumpets are absolutely delicious
and it's a great end to a fantastic
brunch
first off we're gonna make the mix
when you think of
growing up
the smell
and the taste of amazing crumpet
it never leaves you
to make the mix the secret is to bring
the milk up the ball but do not boil it
the minute it boils turn it off and let
it sit there now
flour in
a nice pinch of salt in
now add half a teaspoon of bicarb
that gives it aeration and really lifts
the mixture up all those lovely little
holes a nice pinch of sugar
and then
a teaspoon of yeast dry yeast
now once the milk's boiled turn it off
and add some warm water
about 10 tablespoons 150 mil
that cools down the milk
but more importantly it doesn't destroy
the yeast
half
of the milk in first stop
and give that a really good mix
now the rest of it
[Music]
[Music]
you can just see that there's no lumps
through there as it drips through the
whisk now we're looking for it to double
in size and get nice and light
so pop in a warm place whilst you get on
with the delicious topping
[Music]
beautiful strawberries but caramelized
almost like a very quick strawberry jam
hang on
[Music]
just
slice these
in half
some sugar a couple of tablespoons
we're gonna take the sugar to a nice
light caramel it's just starting to
change color now
turn the gas down and we're gonna add
the strawberries
beautiful
just sweating the strawberries down
quickly and the caramels breaking down
a wonderful glaze
on the strawberries
some lemon
grated into the strawberries
gives it that kind of freshness
that really
starts to break down the strawberries
nice
gas up
smells incredible some lemon juice
touch of balsamo vinegar
and that gives it that really nice
delicious tartness now
off it goes
as the strawberries start to cool down
it will naturally thicken and
set beautifully
nice
[Music]
now for the crumpet
it's almost doubled in size but be very
careful you don't knock the bowl because
it can sort of push out all that air
it's aerated it's nice as light just see
the texture
she's ready to go
to boil it
here we go
instead of making normal small crumpets
i'm making a giant one ideal for sharing
now turn the gas down
you just start to see
a traditional crumpet style
cooking process we want those nice
tiny little holes on top and that crispy
crunchy base
right now
it's time to add the butter and just
slide the butter
down the bag
that gives it a really nice nutty flavor
at the end
fish nice
flip
beautiful
take that out
take the jam
spoon over
the secret is for the juice to sort of
run inside all those little holes
think of that tartness of the balsamic
vinegar the strawberries beautifully
soft
and almost pureed
wrapped
in that delicious caramel
now
finish that
with a nice ball of creme fraiche
let that
sit there and that
is an amazing way of finishing off a
traditional brunch
with something sweet something delicious
and something you're dying to tuck into
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
fruit can be a great healthy option for
brunch and knowing how to get the best
out of it can make all the difference
first up how to peel and cut a mango the
easy way
holding your stalk end up cut either
side of the stone cut all the way into
the flesh making squares without cutting
through the skin then turn it inside out
and carefully cut your pieces off
a great tip to check if a pineapple is
ripe is to pull a leaf out from the top
if it comes away easily it's ripe and
ready for slicing
my tip to get the flesh out of a kiwi is
to simply cut the fruit in half and
scoop it out with a teaspoon
try it it really works
if you have fruit that's not perfectly
ripe the tip is to put a banana in a
paper bag then add your unripe fruit put
in a dark place and the banana will
speed up the ripening process of the
other fruit
you can make a grapefruit puree to
accompany a brunch pancake or a crumpet
in a blender to clean it afterwards add
a cup of warm water and run the machine
for a few seconds
empty out then simply repeat with a drop
of washing up liquid then rinse
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons
top tips and 100 recipes just take your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
of course packed with cooking tips
information and 100 recipes to stake
your life on
so sit back and enjoy my delicious
simple suppers
one of my essential mantras for becoming
a better cook is it's all about building
your confidence and the way to do that
is with practice
the key is to have a repertoire of easy
dishes you want to cook and eat time and
time again and soon you'll be on your
way to becoming a kitchen demon
my first dish keeps it simple but
delivers big time on flavour so it's
sure to become a regular quick supper
fix
spicy tuna fish cakes
i love this recipe why
because it turns this humble ingredient
a can of tuna into something delicious
just
open up
and drain the tuna into a sieve
just lightly flake that
don't press it too hard otherwise you'll
dry out the tuna
now these are water chestnuts
just slice them nice and thin
you can buy them anywhere any
supermarket
chestnuts in
fresh ginger
get rid of that rough skin on the
outside
by grating the ginger you get to get all
that really nice
sort of juice
in
take your spring onions and just slice
on an angle i like the texture of the
water chestnut with a spring onion
or touch of fresh coriander
lovely
next remove the seeds from a chili to
reduce its heat without losing any
flavor
and finely
chilis in
kaffir lime leaves
roll them up
nice and tight
run your knife down the center
once
and just chop
and that makes the fish cake nice and
fragrant
touch of salt
a touch of pepper
fish sauce
just lightly season
the tuna
to bind all those wonderful ingredients
two whole eggs
and give that a nice little whisk
and then
add your eggs get your hands in there
and start mixing
get the mixture
roll it hand to hand
and the palm pat them down nicely
to cook add a little ground oil to a hot
pan
at the face of a clock i'm going to go
from 12 all the way around
first one in
these fish cakes only take a few minutes
to cook so keeping track of the order
they go in the pan means you know which
one to turn first
[Music]
give the pad a nice gentle little shake
make sure that nothing's sticking to the
bottom
spatula
two fingers on top turn them over
beautiful that crackling noise is
something you always want because the
tune's already cooked so we're just
lightly frying them to get a nice crisp
outside and gently
take them out
smell
incredible
let them sit there i'm gonna make a
really nice delicious simple dipping
sauce start off
a little pinch of sugar fish sauce two
tablespoons that gives it the
saltiness one tablespoon of rice wine
vinegar
and some fresh lime juice
squeeze all that lime in there your
fresh coriander
lots of coriander and in
give that
a little mix
and then you have the most amazing spicy
tuna fish cakes who would have thought
something as delicious as that can come
out of a can
a simple supper in minutes that's so
mouth-wateringly easy and delicious
you're guaranteed to cook it again and
again
when it comes to simple cooking there
are two basic bits of kit i'm never
without that will save you time and
effort in the kitchen
a grater and a peeler the swivel peeler
a stainless steel one
absolutely incredible it's almost like a
lifesaver in the kitchen because they
are so quick so light swivel blade so
we've got so much more flexibility
actually go around the vegetable
and we call it speed peeler in the
professional kitchen because it does
literally
absolutely
rapidly peels your vegetables you have
minimal waste
good peelers cost them a couple of quid
and are great for everything from
peeling veg to finely slicing cheese and
making shards of chocolate a good
comfortable grip and a sharp stainless
steel blade ensures you'll always work
fast
[Music]
the box grater is another great
versatile kitchen tool and with its
planes for course grating fine grating
and super fine as well as blades for
slicing it's perfect for everything from
puring ginger and zesting lemons to
shredding onions super small so they can
caramelize in a flash and be sure to get
a solid handle to hold it firm
and it's got such volume inside it
doesn't crush everything up so i always
prefer to grate onto a tray or into a
bowl so you don't have to move it again
creating onto the board you've always
got to lift it up and place it in so
place the grater into a bowl and grate
two simple but essential speedy bits of
kit guaranteed to make your life in the
kitchen easier
[Music]
bread is a brilliant base for delicious
super fast lunches and suppers
here are three of my deliciously simple
recipes that transform a humble bit of
bread into a gastronomic treat
first up flatbreads with fennel and feta
[Music]
add olive oil to a flatbread
[Music]
then place in a hot frying pan and toast
until crisp and golden on both sides
these deliciously versatile breads are
made without yeast and are available in
good supermarkets and local middle
eastern shops
next thinly slice fresh fennel
and scatter over the toasted flatbread
then toast aromatic fennel seeds in a
hot dry pan
and sprinkle on top
crumble over wonderfully tangy feta
cheese
[Music]
finish with a drizzle of sweet and
sticky pomegranate molasses
bread transformed before your eyes
flatbreads with fennel and feta simple
delicious and ready to eat in minutes
[Music]
my next recipe that turns a hunk of
bread into a stunning dish is bruschetta
with garlic tomatoes capers and pecorino
[Music]
start by slicing a baguette diagonally
to get a large surface area so it holds
more of the delicious topping
drizzle the bread with extra virgin
olive oil
then place it oil side down onto a
scorching hot griddle
when the bread is beautifully charred
remove and rub with a pill clove of
garlic pay attention to the edges
next half sweet cherry tomatoes and rub
the juices into the toasted garlic bread
then simply crush on top
[Music]
next slice and scatter over tangy caper
berries
and use a veg peeler to add shavings of
salty pecorino cheese
[Music]
finally drizzle with extra virgin olive
oil and add a twist of black pepper
fantastic fresh flavors in the flesh of
a griddle pan
toast has never tasted so good
[Music]
perfect for a simple light supper or an
easy lunch my next dish is the
cannellini bean crostini with anchovy
and olive oil
[Music]
first for the topping heat olive oil in
a frying pan
add tin cannellini beans along with the
juices
once heated gently mash the beans with a
fork
then add sliced black olives
roughly chop parsley
and a splash of sherry vinegar
season
and leave on a gentle heat
next half a festive batter
and splash with extra virgin olive oil
heat a griddle pan until smoking
and toast the bread all side down
pressing it into the pan to char evenly
to serve
top the toasted chipatta with a cannali
bean mixture
and finish
with chopped anchovies
packed with bold flavors so easy you can
always make it blindfolded ready in
under 10 minutes but eaten in seconds
three different breads three fantastic
recipes
proof that even when you're pressed for
time you can still eat like a king
incredible welcome back to my ultimate
cookery course
[Music]
these are my perfect tv dinners
next up my guide to getting the best
ingredients for your money my shopping
manta is very simple first rely on your
senses make sure whatever you're buying
it looks smells and really feels good
and if you get the chance to taste it
before you buy it then do it
second is to recognize that knowledge is
absolutely crucial the more you know
about where your ingredients are from
and how they produce the better so don't
be scared ask lots of questions and
learn
and when you want a simple supper herbs
are perfect to use in your cooking they
add vibrancy an amazing depth of flavor
and once you get the hang of them they
are so quick and simple to use and one
woman who really knows the chef's best
friends is expert herb grower lorraine
melton
i love herbs i love the way you can cook
with them i love the smell of them
she's been growing an incredible array
of herbs in the wet cambridgeshire
countryside for over 20 years and can
smell a bay from a basil at 50 paces we
grow about 150 varieties of herbs it's
always interesting to grow new varieties
see what they taste like see what they
smell like it gets a bit addictive after
a while
broadly speaking you get harder herbs
and softer herbs softer herbs are things
like parsley basil rocket coriander
we grow um two main types of parsley
we've got flat leaf parsley and curly
parsley flavour-wise i think they're
very similar although a lot of people
would say that the flat leaf parsley has
got a stronger more aromatic flavour
this is your common basil sweet geneves
this is a purple variety called ruben we
do greek basil thai basil holy basil
when you're looking for a basil you want
a bright fresh basil nice leaves no
blemishes and nice strong stems it's got
a lot of oils in it and it's very strong
smelling it just tastes a summer basil
lorraine certainly knows her stuff and
she's right soft herbs are delicate so
for maximum flavor always use them at
the end of cooking or simply add as they
are to cold dishes
here are my top five soft herbs that i
could never live without
[Music]
basil as lorraine said it comes in many
types all with an amazing sweet punch
and flavor great blitzed in pestos
sprinkled whole over mozzarella and
showing its versatility it even makes a
wonderful ice cream
parsley beautifully earthy and intensely
fresh use both the leaves and the stem
for great depth of flavor in savoury
dressing soups and salads
coriander for an amazing hint of citrus
often used in thai dishes coriander is
perfect in curries and chutneys but it
bruises easily so treat it with care
tarragon a staple of french cooking this
has long soft green leaves and a
distinct anti-seed flavour great with
chicken or in rich creamy sauces
[Music]
finally chervil both mild and sweet a
perfect pairing with fish an incredible
mix simply with melted butter for a
quick source those are my favorite soft
herbs what about the hard ones
the harder ones tend to be
a more woody plant
things like thyme rosemary you've got
your common time which is your ordinary
general bog standard cooking time and
then you've got things like lemon thyme
we do an orange thyme which is actually
one of my favorites it smells like thyme
but it's got a deep sort of musky scent
as well which is going to give you a
slightly different flavor in your dish
hard herbs like thyme can take more
intense cooking than soft herbs so
they're great in stews roast or pan
frying choose the right one and you can
add wonderful depth of flavor to your
dishes here are my top five i use day in
and day out
rosemary amazingly robust with great
bittersweet green leaves it's a classic
paired with lamb delicious sprinkled
over speciality breads like focaccia or
great as toppings for fruity sorbets
lorraine's favorite thyme a heady
aromatic pungent herb which adds
delicious flavor to a sunday roast it's
amazing with wild mushrooms and is
perfect in marinades
oregano warm and full of delicious
aromatic oils a staple of great italian
dishes and perfect sprinkled on pizzas
or in pasta sauces
[Music]
sage a strong tasting herb with a
deliciously bitter flavor incredible in
stuffings and with rich meats like pork
or duck
finally bay bitter sweet and spicy it's
delicious simmered in soups stocks and
risottos and just as good dried or fresh
grown herbs is a lot easier than people
think it is on winter boxes in balconies
and it's great you can just open your
window put your hand out and snip some
off
when you're out looking for hers make
sure they're not nice and healthy no
blemishes stems look strong they should
just spring back it's a nice springy
sort of herbs smell obviously is quite
important not all things smell but
obviously if you think it's one that's
going to smell like lemon thyme you
should have a nice fresh lemon scent and
obviously the final one is taste you can
tip a bit off
and taste your herbs and you can see
what they taste like them
whether bored from a supermarket or pig
from your window box herb's a great way
to add fresh flavors to your dishes
perfect for delicious simple suppers
[Music]
even if you got a super busy lifestyle
it doesn't mean missing out on delicious
desserts they just have to be simple to
make
when it comes to cooking at home
puddings should always be a pleasure and
never a chore and homemade puds are 100
guaranteed to impress
my next recipe has only two main
ingredients but simplicity doesn't mean
food can't taste out of this world
incredible griddle pineapple with spiced
caramel
if you're making a dessert for one or
two it's gonna be quick and easy this
sumptuous delicious griddle pineapple
fits the bill perfectly
pineapple
a way of testing it's nice and ripe
top of the leaves come out perfect ready
to go
always cut a pineapple with a serrated
edge knife
slice off the bottom
turn it back over
and slice the top part
now
keep that
for later
look at the core
the center of the pineapple and slice
down
directly in half
slice that in half
take each quarter and slice them
smells incredible lay down flat and just
slice
that core off
so you've got this perfect
sort of boat of pineapple
slice underneath
but stop
as you get
right at the end slicing around the skin
will make the pineapple easier to eat
but leaving it attached gives you more
control as it cooks
next heat a griddle pan as hot as you
can
start off
in the corner and push it down
so you really mark the pineapple
two minutes on each side
and then just
turn them
really nice color man look at that
beautiful
i'm gonna sprinkle them
with a little touch of sugar that's
gonna glaze them
now
slice the top
take out these beautiful glazed
slices of pineapple
there
next up the spiced caramel
now start off with your pan
nice and hot
sprinkle
four tablespoons of sugar in there
just flatten it
then add the seeds from a fresh vanilla
pod
in
a small dusting of chinese fly spice
never stir caramel let it sort of bubble
and transform
here she goes
now i've got the color i want it that's
the perfect color off with the gas
in with the butter and then
a couple of tablespoons of cream
lovely and then give that
a little whisk add the rest of your
cream
nice
and just
drip
that spicy caramel
over your pineapple
[Music]
wow
simple elegant and seriously impressive
griddle pineapple with spiced caramel a
delicious treat all to yourself that
tastes even better shared
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
first up the proper way to chop fresh
herbs to get maximum flavor
chopping herbs the secret is to chop
them not bruise them now basil
this is a soft herb so treat it with
some respect when people go mad chopping
herbs all the goodness comes out on the
board i want the goodness left inside
the basil
place them all inside one another with
the largest
leaf at the bottom and it's almost like
rolling a cigar
large one at the bottom small ones in
the center
and then look place them down together
just roll them nice and gently don't
bruise them
step one
rolled ready to slice
sharp knife imperative fingers
tucked in
the bottom part of your knuckle is the
guide between you and the herbs
that there
stops you from cutting your finger
really important to get comfortable with
a knife and just practice rolling the
knife across the board and relaxing that
wrist it's all in the wrist action so
herbs
up
fingernails tucked
underneath and just up and down
up and down
and there you have
a chopped basil that's not bruised
and smelling very fragra
right coriander so you get the bunch of
coriander hold it down
and just lightly shave the leaves
off the stalks
bunch them up together and then just
again let the knife do the work take the
fingernails in and just chop once
and once early don't
hack it
just chop it you can always identify
when you've bruised the herb when you've
removed the herbs off the board there's
a big green patch
mmm
full of flavour and none of the goodness
is left on the chopping board
a great tip for using leftover herbs
simply chop finely mix into butter roll
up in clim film and freeze
then when you want a herby hit cut into
slices and melt over steaks chicken or
veg
asparagus is great for a simple supper
to prepare always remove the lower woody
stem by gently bending and the asparagus
will snap at the perfect point
then boil or steam and serve with a
little of my herb butter
for a cracking soft boiled egg simply
place your egg in boiling water add a
splash of vinegar and cook for exactly
eight minutes
then plunge into ice water the vinegar
helps the shell peel off easily and the
ice water stops the egg from cooking
giving you the perfect runny yolk
[Music]
for fuss-free salad dressings simply add
the ingredients into a jam jar screw the
lid on tightly and shake to combine in
seconds there's no need to wash up a
whisk and the jar is ready made to store
any leftovers
follow my ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons
top tips
and 100 recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking